au rez documenté souvent réactualisé ce
site internet et dont il donne des
conseils pratiques aux internautes il
leur suffit doc situe ici pour apprendre
comment s'entraîner pour le jihad la
guerre sainte
il interprète aussi de façon très
tendancieuse de multiples sourates du
coran
il fait par exemple l'apologie de
l'attentât suicide et ordonne aux
musulmans de rechercher le martyre et
d'infliger des pertes à l'ennemi en
juillet dernier l'association j'accuse
à signaler la dangerosité de ce site
internet au parquet de paris après avoir
fait sa propre enquête
nous avons utilisé le sait qu'on appelle
un traceur pour voir qui qu'il pouvait
se cacher derrière ce site nous avons
localisé le dépositaire le responsable
du domaine st comme prenait quelqu'un
qui vit dans la creuse et nous avons
trouvé quelque chose de très intéressant
en fait la société tvh ici ce n'est pas
une société française mais une société
américaine
localisé dans la vie de misère dans le
connecticut
cet avocat soupçonne donc la société qui
gère ce site en france de n'être qu'une
société écran nous avons tenté de
rencontrer son gérant ici à sardent au
coeur de la creuse
mais l'homme qui a déposé le nom du
domaine st point com a fermé boutique il
ya plus de six mois
il se fait depuis très discret pour
l'instant aucune plainte n'a été déposée
contre nous